From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. On the night of the murder, there's bad weather in Boston. It was raining night and I went back to the foster home. Fred Clay knocks on his foster mother's door. It's late autumn, 1979. Fred has been away for a few days, visiting his cousins and mother in a neighborhood known as Roslandale.
这里是NPR的《Hidden Brain》，我是主持人尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。谋杀案发生的当晚，波士顿天气恶劣。那天晚上雨下个不停，我回到了寄养家庭。弗雷德·克莱敲响了寄养母亲的门。那是1979年的深秋。弗雷德已经离开几天了，去罗兹兰代尔探望他的表亲和母亲。
He knows he is probably in trouble with his foster mother. He hadn't told her he was taking off. I didn't run away. I just went out and they'd come back for a few days. A man opens the door. It's his foster mother's son. He let me in the house, and he was telling me that his mother wanted to talk to me about me not being there for the last few days.
他知道自己可能要因为寄养母亲而惹上麻烦了。他没告诉她自己要出门。我没有离家出走。我只是出去玩了几天，然后回来了。一个男人开了门。是寄养母亲的儿子。他让我进了屋，并告诉我，他母亲想找我谈谈我这几天不在家的事情。
Thankfully for Fred, his foster mother isn't home. She's a church. So he let me in, and I went back to my room. I watched a load of TV. I got some of the e and I eventually fell asleep. Around 9 30 as Fred sleeps, his foster mother returns home. She locks the front door from the inside. So none of the kids in the house can leave overnight. She's the only one with the key. So I was in that room all at all at
幸运的是，弗雷德的寄养母亲不在家。她去教堂了。所以他让我进屋，我回到了自己的房间。我看了很多电视。我吃了一些东西，最后睡着了。大约9点30分，弗雷德正在睡觉时，寄养母亲回到了家。她从里面锁上了前门。这样屋里的孩子们晚上就都出不去了。她是唯一有钥匙的人。所以我一直待在那个房间里，在睡觉。我不知道门被锁上了。我甚至不知道谋杀案正在发生。
time, sleeping. I didn't know the door was locked. I didn't even know the murder was happening. Late that night, a man will be shot to death in Roslanddale. A sleep in his bed, three weeks past his 16th birthday, Fred doesn't know it, Three weeks passed his 16th birthday, Fred doesn't know it, but a boulder is rolling down a hill toward him. In a matter of days, it will make his life unrecognizable. He is going to be arrested for the murder. Various ideas in psychology will be used to decide that he is guilty. This week on Hidden Brain, we go back four decades to retrace the steps of Fred Clay's
那天深夜，一名男子在罗兹兰代尔被枪杀。弗雷德在床上熟睡，他刚过完16岁生日三周，他对此一无所知。刚过完16岁生日三周，弗雷德对此一无所知，但一块巨石正向他滚来。几天之内，他的生活将变得面目全非。他将因这起谋杀案被捕。心理学中的各种观点将被用来判定他有罪。本周的《Hidden Brain》，我们将回到四十年前，重溯弗雷德·克莱被捕和起诉的过程。
arrest and prosecution. And we'll uncover the harm that arises when flawed ideas from psychology are used to to determine that a teenager should spend the rest of his life behind bars. Several hours after Fred Cleary returns to his foster home, cab driver Richard Dwyer is sitting in a taxi. It's around 4 a.m. He sparked in downtown Boston's Red Light District, better known as the Combat Zone. Three men approach the curb. It's late, but the street is lit by the neon lights of a theater and nearby pizza shop.
我们将揭示当心理学中的错误观点被用来判定一个青少年应该在铁窗后度过余生时，所造成的伤害。在弗雷德·克莱回到寄养家庭几个小时后，出租车司机理查德·德怀尔正坐在车里。大约是凌晨4点。他停在波士顿市中心的红灯区，也就是众所周知的“战斗区”。三名男子走近路边。时间很晚了，但街道被剧院和附近披萨店的霓虹灯照亮。
As they get closer, Richard sizes them up. This is something he likes to do with potential customers. For about 30 seconds, he watches them. All three are young black men. One is on the short side, the other two are tall, over six feet. Richard decides the three men look suspicious. He shakes his head at them, and the three turn toward another cab. 28-year-old Jeffrey Boyadgin is behind the wheel. Richard watches them get into the other cab, he's at the end of a 12-hour shift, and he doesn't give the incident any more notice.
当他们靠近时，理查德打量着他们。这是他喜欢对潜在乘客做的事情。他观察了他们大约30秒。这三个人都是年轻的黑人男性。一个比较矮，另外两个很高，超过六英尺。理查德认为这三个人看起来很可疑。他向他们摇了摇头，于是三人转向了另一辆出租车。28岁的杰弗里·博亚吉安坐在驾驶座上。理查德看着他们上了另一辆车，他当时已经结束了12小时的轮班，没有再关注这件事。
And so they went over to Jeffree's cab and he agreed to take them. That's Jeffrey Boyage's younger brother, Jerry Boyage. Jeffrey and the three men drive across the city to Roslandale. They're going to a public housing complex called the Archdale Housing Project. When Jeffrey stops the cab, the three passengers make their real intentions clear. They ended up pulling him out of the cab to Robbym. Inside his apartment, a man named Neil Sweat is getting ready for work. He looks out his second floor window and sees a robbery in progress.
于是他们走到杰弗里的车前，他同意载他们。那是杰弗里·博亚吉安的弟弟，杰瑞·博亚吉安。杰弗里和这三名男子开车穿过城市前往罗兹兰代尔。他们要去一个叫“阿奇代尔住房项目”的公共住房区。当杰弗里停下车时，这三名乘客露出了真实意图。他们最终把他从车里拉出来进行抢劫。在公寓里，一个叫尼尔·斯威特的人正准备去上班。他从二楼的窗户向外看，看到了正在发生的抢劫案。
From a distance of about 75 feet, he watches the scene unfold. It's still just after 4am and dark out except for a single street lamp. The driver yells, leave me alone, let me go. Neil sees the man hitting the cabbie. Jeffrey Boyajin begs for his life. One of the robbers holds Jeffrey while another rifles through his pockets. The shortest of the three walks over to the cab, then walks back to where Jeffrey is lying on the ground. Then he raises his left arm and fires several shots into Jeffrey's head. They killed my brother. The three men vanish.
在大约75英尺的距离外，他目睹了事态的发展。当时刚过凌晨4点，外面很黑，只有一盏路灯。司机大喊：“别管我，放我走。”尼尔看到那个人在殴打出租车司机。杰弗里·博亚吉安恳求饶命。其中一名劫匪按住杰弗里，另一名劫匪翻找他的口袋。三人中最矮的一个走到车边，然后走回杰弗里躺在地上的地方。接着他举起左臂，向杰弗里的头部开了几枪。他们杀了我哥哥。这三名男子消失了。
Minutes later police arrive. They find Jeffrey lying in a pool of his own blood near a dumpster. The cops soon discover Neil Sweat, the man at the second floor window. He's now standing in a nearby doorway. They question him. He tells them he cannot identify the killers. Later that day, Richard Dwyer learns about the murder. He's the cab driver who watched the three men get into Jeffrey's taxi.
几分钟后警察赶到。他们发现杰弗里躺在垃圾桶附近的血泊中。警察很快发现了二楼窗边的尼尔·斯威特。他现在正站在附近的门口。他们盘问他。他告诉他们他无法辨认出凶手。那天晚些时候，理查德·德怀尔得知了这起谋杀案。他就是那个看着三名男子上杰弗里出租车的司机。
He makes a connection to what he saw that morning in the combat zone. He calls the police and tells them. He gives a vague description of the three men. He remembers that two were tall and one was short. Two were wearing dark jackets, one was wearing a light jacket. All three were young black men. wearing a light jacket. All three were young black men. By 2 o'clock on the afternoon of the shooting, the police come up with a photo line up. The pictures are of 12 black men, most of whom either live at the Archdale Housing Project or are known to hang out there. Some of the men have had run-ins with the cops. Fred Clay is one of them.
他将那天早上在“战斗区”看到的情景联系了起来。他打电话给警察并告知了情况。他给出了这三名男子的模糊描述。他记得其中两个很高，一个很矮。两个穿着深色夹克，一个穿着浅色夹克。这三个人都是年轻的黑人男性。穿着浅色夹克。这三个人都是年轻的黑人男性。枪击案当天下午2点，警方制作了一份照片排查表。照片上有12名黑人男性，他们大多住在阿奇代尔住房项目，或者经常在那里出没。其中一些人曾与警察发生过冲突。弗雷德·克莱就是其中之一。
The police ask Richard Dwyer to come in to see if any of the photos jog his memory. Richard will later testify that he has shown the photo line-up and picks out two photos. But Lisa Kavanaugh, a lawyer who has represented Fred in the case, says the evidence suggests the police did something else first. The police decided to hypnotize him. Richard has introduced to the director of the department's hypnosis investigation unit. His name is Patrick Brady. He had been a police officer for 25 years at this point and held a position called the investigative hypnotist. He was quite clear that he didn't consider himself an expert on the nature of hypnotic phenomena and this was only the fifth or sixth person that he had ever hypnotized.
警方要求理查德·德怀尔过来看看这些照片是否能唤起他的记忆。理查德后来作证说，他被展示了照片排查表并挑出了两张照片。但曾在此案中代表弗雷德的律师丽莎·卡瓦诺表示，证据表明警方首先做了别的事情。警方决定对他进行催眠。理查德被介绍给了该部门催眠调查组的负责人。他的名字叫帕特里克·布雷迪。此时他已经当了25年警察，担任“调查催眠师”一职。他非常明确地表示，他不认为自己是催眠现象方面的专家，这只是他催眠过的第五或第六个人。
A few other police detectives and assistant DAs gathered to watch the hypnosis session. Detective Patrick Brady tells Richard that the hypnosis would make it clear in his mind what he had seen the previous evening. A transcript of the hypnosis using police records gives us an idea of what happened next. We had actors recreate the scene. The detective shows Richard a ring. I want you to notice the rose stone in the middle. Uh-huh. Because as you are staring at it,
其他几名警探和助理地方检察官聚集在一起观看催眠过程。警探帕特里克·布雷迪告诉理查德，催眠会让他清楚地想起前一天晚上看到的情景。一份使用警方记录的催眠笔录让我们了解了接下来发生的事情。我们让演员重现了这一场景。警探向理查德展示了一枚戒指。“我希望你注意中间的玫瑰石。嗯。因为当你盯着它看的时候，”
it is starting to become a little hazy. What I'm going to do is I am very slowly going to bring the ring down and your eyelids will follow it down. As they do and they come down with the ring, your eyes will be closed. They will stay closed and you will be very comfortable. He starts to countdown slowly from 20. At each level, Richard is supposed to get more and more relaxed. 7, 6, until 3, 2, 1, so beautiful and so comfortable, so peaceful. Your whole body is peaceful, so relaxed and so heavy.
“它开始变得有点模糊了。我要做的是，我会非常缓慢地把戒指放低，你的眼睑会跟着它向下。当它们合上，随着戒指落下时，你的眼睛就会闭上。它们会保持闭合，你会感到非常舒适。”他开始从20倒数。在每一个数字，理查德都应该变得越来越放松。“7，6，直到3，2，1，太美好了，太舒适了，太宁静了。你的整个身体都很宁静，非常放松，非常沉重。”
Next, the detective tells Richard to imagine himself at home and then to turn his television on. Now, what is going to happen is I am going to turn the channel and when I do, you begin the documentary and you will see it clear in your mind. I am getting ready to turn the channel now. When the documentary begins, it will be of you sometime around 4 o'clock this morning sitting in your cap. I am going to slow the frames down now. They're going very slow, slow motion.
接下来，警探告诉理查德想象自己在家，然后打开电视。“现在，将要发生的是，我要换频道，当我换频道时，你开始看纪录片，你会清楚地在脑海中看到它。我现在准备换频道了。当纪录片开始时，那将是你今天凌晨4点左右坐在出租车里的样子。我现在要放慢帧数。它们会变得非常慢，慢动作。”
Under hypnosis, Richard begins to watch the scene unfold. He describes the three men, their height, what they're wearing. He is tall, skinny. When he arrives at the part where the three get into the cab in front of his, Jeffrey Boyageens cab, Richard starts to get agitated. I'm scared. Scared? There's nothing to be scared of. You're just watching this. They're going to do something bad to him. They're going to do something.
在催眠下，理查德开始观看场景展开。他描述了这三个人，他们的身高，他们穿的衣服。“他很高，很瘦。”当他讲到三人上车，也就是杰弗里·博亚吉安的出租车时，理查德开始变得焦躁不安。“我很害怕。”“害怕？没什么好怕的。你只是在看这个。”“他们要对他做坏事。他们要做些什么。”
I just don't like them. The detective decides to bring Richard out of his trance. One. More relaxed. And more relaxed. Two. Higher. Higher.
“我就是不喜欢他们。”警探决定让理查德从恍惚状态中出来。“一。更放松。更放松。二。更高。更高。”
Three. Four. Four. Four. Four. Relaxed, too higher, higher, three, four, and... Richard has shown the photo line up. He picks out two faces. One is a man named James Watson. The other is a 16-year-old boy, Fred Clay. Stay with us. In the movies, psychological techniques invariably elicit the truth.
“三。四。四。四。四。放松，太高了，更高，三，四，还有……”理查德被展示了照片排查表。他挑出了两张脸。一个是名叫詹姆斯·沃森的人。另一个是16岁的男孩，弗雷德·克莱。请继续收听。在电影中，心理学技巧总是能引出真相。
A clever manipulation here, a trick question there, and suspects reveal all. Shortly before police hypnotize cab driver Richard Dwyer, here's what moviegoers are seeing. This is from the 1977 movie, Audrey Rose. Well, I have never participated in or witnessed such an event. I am here at the behest of the court to perform a function for which I have been trained and I'm licensed to perform. Now, I will be hypnotizing the subject who will be brought to me while you watch. Today you hear that kind of stuff and think okay it's Hollywood. But at the time hypnosis
这里巧妙的操纵，那里一个陷阱问题，嫌疑人就会全盘托出。在警方催眠出租车司机理查德·德怀尔前不久，电影观众看到的是这样的画面。这是1977年的电影《奥黛丽·罗斯》。“好吧，我从未参与或目睹过这样的事件。我受法庭之托，来执行我受过培训并获得许可执行的职能。现在，我将催眠受试者，当你们观看时，他会被带到我这里。”今天你听到这些东西会觉得“好吧，那是好莱坞”。但在当时，催眠
seemed like a powerful technique to get at the truth. Police use hypnosis to calm crime victims who are so traumatized I can't tell a coherent story or to sharpen the recall of witnesses who can't remember details. The earliest case on record that used hypnotically elicited testimony was in 1897. Starting in the late 1960s, it became common for police to use hypnosis and some courts allowed it. But the method received national attention as a viable forensic tool, not long before Fred's case. In 1976, a bus driver who had been buried alive was reportedly able to recall his kidnappers' license plate number while under the influence of hypnosis. Still, even then, some experts pushed back against using hypnosis as a forensic tool. To tell the truth, the whole truth, and nothing but the truth is what witnesses are required to swear before giving testimony in court.
似乎是一种获取真相的强大技术。警方利用催眠来安抚那些因受创伤而无法讲述连贯故事的犯罪受害者，或者用来强化那些记不清细节的证人的记忆。有记录的最早使用催眠证词的案件是在1897年。从20世纪60年代末开始，警方使用催眠变得普遍，一些法院也允许这样做。但这种方法作为一种可行的法医工具受到全国关注，是在弗雷德案发生前不久。1976年，一名被活埋的公交车司机据称在催眠状态下回忆起了绑架者的车牌号。尽管如此，即使在当时，一些专家也反对将催眠作为法医工具。“说真话，说全部的真话，除了真话什么都不说”，这是证人在法庭作证前必须宣誓的内容。
However, there is rising concern that one method of getting at the truth may in fact be undermining that pledge. The issue was debated during Fred's case. At the time, there was not a clear consensus about how valid it was to use hypnosis in criminal proceedings. It's an issue both scientific and legal, on one level and inquiry into the nature of memory. On another, a classic controversy over the use of scientific tools by non-scientists. By the 1980s, state courts started making it more difficult, sometimes impossible, to
然而，人们越来越担心，这种获取真相的方法实际上可能正在破坏这一誓言。这个问题在弗雷德案中引起了争论。当时，对于在刑事诉讼中使用催眠的有效性，并没有明确的共识。这是一个既科学又法律的问题，一方面是对记忆本质的探究，另一方面是关于非科学家使用科学工具的经典争议。到了20世纪80年代，州法院开始加大难度，有时甚至不可能
admit testimony obtained via hypnosis. Around the same time, new scientific insights about the malleability of memory were becoming more widely known. They discredited the idea that memory works like a video recording. It's unclear how many people have been convicted on the basis of hypnosis. Today, 17 states still allow hypnotically induced testimony, even though most psychologists question the idea. Memory does not work like that, does not work like a video camera or a DVR.
采纳通过催眠获得的证词。大约在同一时间，关于记忆可塑性的新科学见解变得广为人知。它们推翻了记忆像录像一样工作的观点。目前还不清楚有多少人是基于催眠被定罪的。今天，仍有17个州允许催眠诱导的证词，尽管大多数心理学家对此表示怀疑。“记忆不是那样工作的，不像摄像机或硬盘录像机那样工作。”
Sam Summers is a psychologist at Tafts University. It's quite problematic when it comes to eyewitness memory. Your goal is to get people to get to their, to the actual memory for the actual scene in question. If they didn't encode them at the time, it's probably not there to be retrieved. Researchers have come to realize that memory is not just fallible, but is almost always reconstructed. We had an episode of Hidden Brain that talks about this idea. It's called, did that really happen?
萨姆·萨默斯是塔夫茨大学的心理学家。“当涉及到目击者记忆时，这非常成问题。你的目标是让人回到他们对所讨论场景的实际记忆。如果他们当时没有编码，那么它可能根本就不存在，无法被检索。”研究人员已经意识到，记忆不仅容易出错，而且几乎总是被重构的。我们有一期《Hidden Brain》讨论过这个观点。它叫“那真的发生过吗？”
Our memories are shaped by our expectations, imaginations, and preconceived notions. Even the conversations we have, or the media we consume after an event has occurred, can reshape our recollection of it. Of course, that's not the way it feels inside our heads. Many of us trust our memories, especially of significant events. Memory does feel like a hard drive that you can somehow search with the right key terms, or a DVR that you can somehow pull things back from.
我们的记忆受到我们的期望、想象力和先入之见的影响。甚至我们在事件发生后进行的对话或消费的媒体，也会重塑我们对它的回忆。当然，这并不是我们大脑内部的感觉。我们许多人信任自己的记忆，尤其是对重大事件的记忆。记忆确实感觉像是一个硬盘，你可以用正确的关键词搜索，或者像一个硬盘录像机，你可以从中提取东西。
And the subjective feeling that comes along with it perhaps is a large part why it's hard to disabuse some people, including attorneys and judges and jurors of the notion that that's how memory actually works. The gap between our intuitive understanding of how our minds work and the reality of how our minds actually work can sound arcane. Try telling cops or jurors that memory is reconstructed and fallible, and they will likely dismiss you as an out-of-touch egghead. But in very real ways, this gap drives some of the systemic bias we see in the criminal
而随之而来的主观感觉，也许是很难让一些人（包括律师、法官和陪审员）摒弃“记忆就是这样运作的”这一观念的重要原因。我们对大脑运作方式的直觉理解与大脑实际运作方式的现实之间的差距，听起来可能很深奥。试着告诉警察或陪审员记忆是重构的且容易出错的，他们很可能会把你当作一个脱离现实的书呆子。但以非常真实的方式，这种差距导致了我们在刑事
justice system. There are a few things that are more persuasive to a jury than hearing a confident eyewitness say on the witness stand. I will never forget that face your honor. It's the guy sitting right there. It's incredibly powerful for a jury to hear that. I think we have this lay intuition that especially when it comes to the really important things like if I'm the victim of a crime or if I'm
司法系统中看到的一些系统性偏见。很少有什么东西比听到一个自信的目击者在证人席上说“法官大人，我永远不会忘记那张脸。就是坐在那里的那个人”更能说服陪审团了。这对陪审团来说非常有震撼力。我认为我们有一种朴素的直觉，尤其是当涉及到真正重要的事情时，比如如果我是犯罪受害者，或者如果我是
a witness to a murder, I mean I'm gonna get that right I'm gonna remember that. After being hypnotized, Richard Dwyer became a very confident witness. I pictured in my mind's eye, I could picture the scene that was in the eye. Here he is, describing what he'd seen under hypnosis and the clarity it produced in him. It was very clear to me, it was almost like a TV screen. We reached out to Richard for our story, but he didn't respond to our request. Loyalisa Kavanaugh says he still stands behind his identification, four decades later. Once you've been told that, as an eyewitness, it's really hard not to believe the strength
谋杀案的目击者，我的意思是，我会记对的，我会记住的。在被催眠后，理查德·德怀尔成了一个非常自信的证人。“我在脑海中想象，我可以想象出那个场景。”这是他描述在催眠下看到的情景以及它带给他的清晰感。“对我来说非常清晰，就像电视屏幕一样。”我们联系了理查德以获取我们的故事，但他没有回应我们的请求。丽莎·卡瓦诺说，四十年后，他仍然坚持他的辨认。一旦你被告知这一点，作为目击者，真的很难不相信你所拥有的
of the memory that you have. Armed with their new leads into the killing, police go back to the housing project in Roslanddale to talk to their other witness, Neil Sweat. Remember, the first time police talked to Neil, he said he couldn't identify anyone. Police showed Neil the photo line up. Neil looks at the photos. No, he says't identify anyone. Police showed Neil the photo line up. Neil looks at the photos. No, he says. Still nothing. Police likely pick up a couple of things about Neil's sweat. One is, he appears to be intellectually disabled.
记忆的强度。带着关于这起杀人案的新线索，警方回到罗兹兰代尔的住房项目，与他们的另一位证人尼尔·斯威特交谈。记住，警察第一次和尼尔谈话时，他说他认不出任何人。警察向尼尔展示了照片排查表。尼尔看着照片。“不，”他说。还是什么都没有。警察可能发现了关于尼尔·斯威特的几件事。一是，他似乎有智力障碍。
Later, according to public records, he is shown to be severely impaired. The second thing that police discover is that Neil and his family want out of the housing project. They've been on a wait list for alternate housing for five years. The next day, Sunday, the police come back with the same photo line up. And that's when detectives tell Neil two things. They tell him that they have a pretty good idea who the killers are and just need its
后来，根据公共记录，他被证明有严重的功能障碍。警察发现的第二件事是，尼尔和他的家人想搬出这个住房项目。他们已经在替代住房的等待名单上排了五年了。第二天，星期天，警察带着同样的照片排查表回来了。就在那时，警探告诉尼尔两件事。他们告诉他，他们很清楚凶手是谁，只需要他的
help in confirming things. And they also tell him, if you cooperate with us, we'll get you out of Archdale. Neil looks at the photos. Again, nothing. But the police don't give up. There was an effort after that meeting to hypnotize him. So although Mr. Sweat, having seen a ray now twice, was unable to pick any photographs, he agreed to undergo hypnosis. And so he went to the station that night and they attempted to put him under hypnosis,
帮助来确认一下。他们还告诉他：“如果你配合我们，我们会让你搬出阿奇代尔。”尼尔看着照片。还是什么都没有。但警察没有放弃。在那次会面后，他们曾试图催眠他。所以，尽管斯威特先生现在已经看过两次照片，但他无法挑出任何照片，他还是同意接受催眠。于是那天晚上他去了警察局，他们试图对他进行催眠，
but terminated the session after deciding that he didn't have his concentration was too poor. And so at this point they've shown the array to Neil twice. They've told him, essentially we know who was involved. The person who's showing it to him is the same person who was present for Mr. Dwyer's identification procedure and knows exactly which two people in the array had been selected by Mr. Dwyer so he knows who the target suspects are. Neal leaves the police station and heads home. The next day, Monday, police come calling again. Counting the night of the murder, this is the fourth time they are asking him to make an identification. They spread out the
但在决定他的注意力太差后终止了会话。所以此时他们已经向尼尔展示了两次照片。他们基本上告诉他：“我们知道谁参与了。”向他展示照片的人，正是理查德·德怀尔辨认程序时在场的那个人，他确切地知道照片中哪两个人被理查德选中了，所以他知道目标嫌疑人是谁。尼尔离开警察局回家了。第二天，星期一，警察又来了。算上谋杀案发生的当晚，这是他们第四次要求他进行辨认。他们把
photos before him on the kitchen table. The police offer another assurance that they will relocate the family that they had made specific arrangements and that it would happen at the city of Boston's expense. And it was at that point that Neil Sweat picked out Fred Clay and picked out James Watson and indicated that he knew one of them, Freddie, by his first name. I want to pause here a moment to draw your attention to something. Neil Sweat, new Fred Clay from Archdale.
照片摊在他面前的厨房桌子上。警察再次保证他们会安置这家人，他们已经做了具体的安排，而且费用由波士顿市承担。就在那时，尼尔·斯威特挑出了弗雷德·克莱，挑出了詹姆斯·沃森，并表示他认识其中一个人，弗雷迪，叫他的名字。我想在这里暂停一下，引起你们对某件事的注意。尼尔·斯威特认识阿奇代尔的弗雷德·克莱。
He had been shown Fred's picture in the photo lineup on two previous occasions. This is the picture of someone he knows, and he said he could not identify the shooter. Imagine you saw a murder. Imagine also that the killer is someone you know. Police placed this man's photo before you on two separate occasions and you say you can't recognize the man. Then, on round three, you say you can. Now, you might say there is a simple explanation for this.
他在之前的两次照片排查中都被展示过弗雷德的照片。这是他认识的人的照片，而他说他无法辨认出枪手。想象一下你目睹了一场谋杀。再想象一下，凶手是你认识的人。警察在两个不同的场合把这个人的照片放在你面前，而你说你认不出这个人。然后，在第三轮，你说你能了。现在，你可能会说这有一个简单的解释。
Maybe Nielswear did recognize Fred Clair from the start, but was afraid to identify someone to the police that he knew from the housing project. Maybe he feared for his safety. In fact, Neil did tell the cops he was afraid to get involved. Maybe. But Lisa Kavanaugh and other experts say there is a better explanation, and it has to do with three psychological errors that police made in the investigation, errors that many police departments still make today.
也许尼尔·斯威特从一开始就认出了弗雷德·克莱，但害怕向警察指认他在住房项目认识的人。也许他担心自己的安全。事实上，尼尔确实告诉警察他害怕卷入其中。也许吧。但丽莎·卡瓦诺和其他专家表示，有一个更好的解释，这与警方在调查中犯下的三个心理学错误有关，这些错误是许多警察部门今天仍在犯的。
There's since the time of this investigation been extensive research on the importance of blind identification procedures, and of blind identification procedures. And what blind identification procedure refers to is a procedure in which the person who is displaying the photographs or displaying suspects in a live array doesn't know who the target suspects are. You don't need to leap to the idea of police misconduct to see why it's problematic when an officer has suspects in mind as he's asking a witness to make an identification. Even if the sort of assuming the best of intentions on the part of the police, there have been
自这次调查以来，关于盲辨认程序的重要性已经有了广泛的研究。盲辨认程序是指展示照片或在现场排查中展示嫌疑人的人，不知道谁是目标嫌疑人。你不需要跳到警察不当行为的结论，就能明白当警官在要求证人进行辨认时心中已有嫌疑人，为什么这会有问题。即使假设警察的意图是最好的，也有
studies showing that other more subtle cues including body language can lead the police to sort of guide witnesses toward a particular person or people in an array. The second problem potentially affected both Richard Dwyer and Neil Sweat. Both witnesses were white. Psychologist Sam Summers says that he has often struggled as an expert on courtroom stands to convince jurors that when a witness makes an identification, they need to factor in the question of race.
研究表明，包括肢体语言在内的其他更微妙的线索，会导致警察在某种程度上引导证人指向排查表中的特定个人。第二个问题可能同时影响了理查德·德怀尔和尼尔·斯威特。两位证人都是白人。心理学家萨姆·萨默斯说，作为法庭上的专家，他经常努力说服陪审员，当证人进行辨认时，他们需要考虑种族问题。
The way I've often explained this to a jury is there are two jobs basically that you ask a witness to do to accurately say yes, that is the person I saw, but also to accurately say no, that is not the person I saw when it's not. And researching just that for both of those jobs, we tend to do a better job of that as a witness when we're dealing with faces that are of our own racial and ethnic in groups as opposed to faces of the out group, other racial or ethnic groups. The third problem had to do with neo Sweat's cognitive impairments. The research shows that police interrogations are inherently coercive. Chris Henning is a legal scholar at Georgetown University.
我经常向陪审团解释这一点的方式是，你要求证人做两项基本工作：准确地说“是的，那是我看到的人”，但也准确地说“不，那不是我看到的人”（当事实并非如此时）。研究表明，对于这两项工作，作为证人，当我们在处理与我们自己种族和民族内群体相同的面孔时，往往比处理外群体（其他种族或民族群体）的面孔做得更好。第三个问题与尼尔·斯威特的认知障碍有关。研究表明，警察审讯本质上是强制性的。克里斯·亨宁是乔治城大学的法律学者。
She says Neil Sweat may have felt especially coerced by the persistent demands of the police. That's because of his intellectual disability. Folks who fit any of these categories are particularly vulnerable to the pressures of police interrogation. We reached out to Neil Sweat for our story but he did not respond to our request. The night before Jeffrey Boyajin was murdered, Fred Clay had gone to bed knowing his foster mother was upset with him. He had been away for a few days and had broken the curfew rules in his foster home. The next morning, she kicked him out and he was taken to a juvenile detention center in Halifax, Massachusetts. Fred remembers the moment the police came for him.
她说，尼尔·斯威特可能因为警察的持续要求而感到特别被强迫。这是因为他的智力障碍。符合这些类别的人特别容易受到警察审讯压力的影响。我们联系了尼尔·斯威特以获取我们的故事，但他没有回应我们的请求。在杰弗里·博亚吉安被谋杀的前一天晚上，弗雷德·克莱上床睡觉时知道寄养母亲对他很生气。他离开几天了，违反了寄养家庭的宵禁规定。第二天早上，她把他赶了出去，他被带到了马萨诸塞州哈利法克斯的一个少年拘留中心。弗雷德记得警察来找他的那一刻。
The door squeak all the time, the door opened, it squeaks. I saw some playing cozy tights coming there and they went to the main desk and they talked to the council for about 10 minutes and something like that. Then right after that the council got on the paging system and he called my name. I had a delay, come to the main desk please. So I went there and the police officer asked me, is your name Frederick Clay? I said, yes, my name is Frederick Clay. They said, well, we need to talk to you about something. So they took me into a little room off to the side.
“门一直在吱吱作响，门开了，它吱吱作响。我看到一些穿着制服的人走进来，他们走到主台，和辅导员谈了大约10分钟左右。就在那之后，辅导员通过广播系统叫了我的名字。‘弗雷德，请到主台来。’所以我去了那里，警察问我，‘你的名字是弗雷德里克·克莱吗？’我说，‘是的，我的名字是弗雷德里克·克莱。’他们说，‘好吧，我们需要和你谈谈某件事。’于是他们把我带到了旁边的一个小房间里。”
They told me I was being arrested for murder of a cab driver and I said, excuse me, you got the wrong person. I was never in the cab. I said, I'm here for violation of probation. They said what we know about that, but we also got a warrant for your arrest for murder. I kept repeating them that they make a mistake. They got the wrong person. They should have called my probation officer.
“他们告诉我，我因谋杀一名出租车司机而被捕，我说，‘对不起，你们找错人了。我从来没坐过那辆车。我说，我在这里是因为违反缓刑规定。’他们说，‘我们知道那件事，但我们还有一张逮捕你的谋杀令。’我一直重复说他们弄错了。他们找错人了。他们应该给我的缓刑官打电话。”
They should have called my foster parent. They should have called my foster parent. They can verify where I was at. I just kept repeating that. They can try to make them understand that they got the wrong person. The police would have none of it. They were sure they had the right person. When we come back, how Fred Clay was blamed for a lack of remorse over a crime he did not commit. The Boston of Fred Clay's childhood was an unsettling place for a black boy. His neighborhood, Roslandale, was mostly white, but they had
“他们应该给我的寄养父母打电话。他们可以证明我在哪里。我只是不断重复这一点。他们可以试着让他们明白他们找错人了。”警察根本不听。他们确信他们抓对了人。当我们回来时，弗雷德·克莱是如何因为对自己没有犯下的罪行缺乏悔意而受到指责的。弗雷德·克莱童年时代的波士顿对一个黑人男孩来说是一个令人不安的地方。他的社区，罗兹兰代尔，大部分是白人，但他们有
osteoporjects and it was mostly blacks and Spanish and some white people as well, Caucasian people, but back then it was a lot of racial tension because it was in the bushing area. Boston was at the beginning of a court-mandated order to desegregate its public schools. Boston was found guilty of willfully creating and perpetuating a segregated school system. Students were bussed between predominantly white and black areas of the city. The effort fueled a backlash against desegregation from white people and a series of protests gripped the city. The anger has manifested itself throughout the desegregation.
住房项目，那里大部分是黑人和西班牙裔，也有一些白人，高加索人，但那时有很多种族紧张关系，因为它在公交区域。波士顿正处于法院强制命令废除公立学校种族隔离的初期。波士顿被判故意创建和延续种族隔离的学校系统。学生们在城市中以白人为主和以黑人为主的区域之间乘车往返。这一努力引发了白人对废除种族隔离的强烈抵制，一系列抗议活动席卷了这座城市。愤怒在整个废除种族隔离的过程中表现出来。
In the first days, there were isolated incidents of violence when school buses carrying black children were stoned in South Boston. So I was being called the N word a lot. I was just being called that a lot and being chased a lot and being given to a lot of fights because of my color. I remember one incident that I was just being called out a lot and being chased a lot and being and getting to a lot of fights because of my color. I remember one incident I was coming back from Dorchester.
在最初的几天里，发生了零星的暴力事件，载有黑人儿童的校车在南波士顿被投掷石块。“所以我经常被叫‘黑鬼’。我经常被那样叫，经常被追赶，因为我的肤色而陷入很多打斗。我记得有一次……”我经常被那样叫，经常被追赶，因为我的肤色而陷入很多打斗。我记得有一次我从多切斯特回来。
Fred was walking down the steps to the train platform when a group of young white men spotted him. One guy started talking to me asking me where I was going and what you're doing around here, you don't belong here. It was sort of just making me aware that I wasn't supposed to be there. We just started arguing and then one guy, he took a swing at me. He hit me on my side of my face. I was kind of days, I should have shook it off a little bit. I tried to run. And I ran right in the middle of traffic.
弗雷德正走下火车站台的台阶，一群年轻的白人男子发现了他。“一个人开始和我说话，问我要去哪里，我在附近做什么，我不属于这里。这只是让我意识到我不应该在那里。我们开始争吵，然后一个人，他向我挥了一拳。他打在我的脸侧。我有点晕，我本应该甩掉它。我试图逃跑。我直接跑进了车流中。”
There was all kind of street traffic, cars going everywhere. I was trying to run to my house, but at the same time, I realized that my house was too far. I didn't want to run all that way. So I just stopped right in the middle of the street, traffic coming and everything else, and just stopped fighting them.
“到处都是街道交通，汽车到处乱窜。我试图跑回家，但同时，我意识到我的家太远了。我不想跑那么远。所以我只是停在街道中间，车流和其他东西都过来了，我只是停止了与他们的打斗。”
At that time, I was like 12 years old. Even at home, Fred did not find refuge. He lived with his mother and three siblings. On the oldest of four, and back then, my mother had an alcohol issue. She was alcoholic. She was always drunk. There was no food in the house. She was alcoholic. She was always drunk. There was no food in the house. It was just a whole lot of neglect. She was beating me.
“那时，我大约12岁。”即使在家里，弗雷德也没有找到避难所。他和母亲以及三个兄弟姐妹住在一起。“我是四个孩子中最大的，那时，我母亲有酗酒问题。她是酒鬼。她总是喝醉。家里没有食物。她是酒鬼。她总是喝醉。家里没有食物。那简直就是完全的忽视。她打我。”
She was beating my sister. She was beating my brother. She would hit me with a switch. She would hit me with a belt. She hit me with a stench record. She beat me one time with a golf club. She was just picking up anything that she can get and hit me with it.
“她打我妹妹。她打我弟弟。她会用鞭子打我。她会用皮带打我。她用唱片打我。她有一次用高尔夫球杆打我。她只是随手拿起任何她能拿到的东西打我。”
So, just anything she wanted to pick up, she was hitting me with it. And me being the oldest, I sort of took the family role as the man in the house sort of speak. It was pretty much up to me to start making money and putting food on the table and stuff like that. So even at the age of 12, 11 years old, I was like sort of like a man in a house. Fred earned money babysitting, helping people load groceries into their cars and shoveling driveways. Sometimes he also stole clothes
“所以，任何她想拿的东西，她都用它打我。而作为老大，我承担了家里男人的角色，可以这么说。开始赚钱、把食物放在桌子上之类的事情基本上都取决于我。所以即使在12岁、11岁的时候，我就像家里的男人一样。”弗雷德通过做保姆、帮人把杂货装进车里和铲车道积雪来赚钱。有时他也偷衣服
or car batteries. I was just trying to help any way I could and I really don't know, I was just trying. Eventually Fred got into trouble with the police. One incident stands out in his mind. This gentleman, he was a French guy, he lived in the projects, and every now and then he would reach out to me to try to clean his apartment form. That's another way I was making money by cleaning his apartment. And one particular morning, I think it was in the summer time. I got up, I got dressed, and I went outside. And for some reason, I don't know what led me to this, but I ended up breaking into his house for some reason.
或汽车电池。“我只是想尽我所能提供帮助，我真的不知道，我只是在尝试。”最终弗雷德惹上了警察。有一件事在他脑海中记忆犹新。“这位先生，他是个法国人，住在项目里，时不时地他会找我帮他打扫公寓。这是我赚钱的另一种方式，通过打扫他的公寓。有一个特定的早晨，我想是在夏天。我起床，穿好衣服，走到外面。出于某种原因，我不知道是什么导致我这样做，但我最终因为某种原因闯入了他的房子。”
And the police came. And it was a big commotion. A lot of people in the project saw me. My mother heard about it. So that was an embarrassing moment. And I regretted it at that moment. And I still regretted it. doing it now, thinking about that now, I still regret it. Looking back now with the advantage of hindsight, what do you think was going on in that teenage boy's head? Well, that time I was smoking a lot of marijuana. I was in between
“警察来了。那是一场大骚动。项目里的很多人都看到了我。我母亲听说了这件事。所以那是一个尴尬的时刻。我在那一刻感到后悔。我现在仍然后悔。现在回想起来，我仍然感到后悔。”回首往事，你认为那个十几岁的男孩脑子里在想什么？“嗯，那时我抽了很多大麻。我在两份工作之间，我需要一些钱，不仅是为了嗨，也是为了尝试为自己以及我的姐妹和兄弟们弄点食物放在桌子上。我只是在想办法赚钱，出于某种原因，我想到了他，我想到了闯入他的房子。我不能告诉你为什么那个想法出现在我的脑海里，但它确实出现了。”到弗雷德16岁时，他与警察的互动使他被送进了D.Y.S.
jobs and I needed some money not only just to get high but just to put to try to put some food on a table for myself as well as my sisters and brothers. I'm just trying to figure out a way to make money and for some reason I thought of him and I thought about breaking to his house. I can't tell you why that thought came into my mind, but it did. By the time Fred was 16, his interactions with the police got him committed to D.Y.S.
即青少年服务部。“我被收容了。我进入了一个长期住院项目。在那个项目中待了大约六个月后，他们把我安置在一个寄养家庭。我想那些人，心理学家，治疗师，他们决定我最好的去处是寄养家庭。”
the Department of Youth Services. And I got committed. And I went to a long-term residential program. And after I stayed in that program for about six months, they placed me in a foster home. I guess the people, the psychologists, the therapists, they decided that the best place for me was to be in a foster home.
我们已经知道弗雷德故事接下来的发展。他去了一个寄养家庭，但在杰弗里·博亚吉安被杀后的第二天早上被赶了出来。从那里，他被送往一个少年拘留中心，警察在那里逮捕了他并指控他犯有一级谋杀罪。在杀人案发生时，弗雷德刚过完16岁生日几周。这是心理学中的错误理论塑造弗雷德命运的下一个节点。在法庭上，弗雷德的律师努力让他留在少年司法系统中，因为那里的后果
We already know what happened next in Fred's story. He went to live in a foster home, but was kicked out the morning after Jeffrey Boyageans killing. From there, he was sent to a juvenile detention center where police arrested him and charged him with first-degree murder. At the time of the killing, Fred was a few weeks past his 16th birthday. This is the next point at which flawed theories from psychology shape what happens to Fred. In court, Fred's attorney fought to keep him in the juvenile system where the consequences
会不那么严重。检察官有不同的计划。他们想把我当作成年人来审判。当时，马萨诸塞州有一个程序叫“转移听证会”。这意味着如果一个少年要面临成年刑事指控的全部后果，必须先在少年法庭进行听证。在这个过程中，一位心理学家给弗雷德做了罗夏墨迹测试。这个测试是在20世纪初开发的，当时赫尔曼·罗夏想出了
would be less severe. Prosecutors had a different plan. They wanted to drive me as a doll. At the time, Massachusetts had a procedure called a transfer hearing. It meant that if a juvenile was going to face the full consequences of an adult criminal charge, there had to be a hearing in juvenile court first. During this process, a psychologist gave Fred a Rorschach test. This test was developed in the early part of the 20th century when Herman Rorschach came
一系列墨迹图。当你看着墨迹图时看到的图形和形状，据称给了专家一个窥探你内心的秘密窗口。弗雷德根本不知道为什么有人要求他解释墨迹斑点。他刚过十六岁，被指控犯有一级谋杀罪。发生了很多事情。他只是照做了。“我只是给了他们我的答案，他们告诉我，‘看着它，告诉我你看到了什么。’”
up with a series of inkplots. The figures and shapes you saw when you looked at the inkplots supposedly gave experts a secret window into your mind. Fred had no idea why someone was asking him to interpret splotches of ink. He was a little past sixteen, being accused of first degree murder. There was a lot going on. He just did what he was told. I just gave him my ass so they told me, look at it and tell me what I thought.
“我只是告诉他们我看到的，图片看起来像什么。”最终，弗雷德的回答据称揭示了他的思想是扭曲的，他是危险的。少年转移听证会的法官在查看了所有证据后决定，弗雷德并不是真正的孩子。把他当作成年人来考虑更好，因为他没有表现出向好的能力。他说：“我发现这个少年弗雷德里克·克莱自事件发生以来，无论是通过行动还是表达，都没有表现出任何悔意。”记住，此时，弗雷德还没有被判任何罪。
I just told him what I thought, the picture looked like. Eventually, Fred's responses would supposedly reveal that his mind was twisted, that he was dangerous. A judge in the juvenile transfer hearing decided after looking at all the evidence that Fred wasn't really a child. It was better to think of him as an adult because he didn't show a capacity to change for the better. He said, I find that this juvenile Frederick Clay has exhibited no remorse, either by action or expression, since this event occurred. Remember, at this point, Fred had not been convicted of anything.
在法律眼中，他应该是无辜的。弗雷德无法理解为什么他被要求为他没有做过的事情表现出悔意。“我知道我没有杀任何人。我知道我从来没去过波士顿市中心。我从来没去过‘战斗区’。所以我认为他们犯了一个可怕的错误。”同样，心理学理论，这次是关于罪责的，将塑造弗雷德的案件。在随后的几十年里，这些理论将被修订。2012年，最高法院的一项里程碑式裁决称，下级法院在将青少年当作成年人对待时犯了错误。
He was supposed to be innocent in the eyes of the law. Fred couldn't understand why he was expected to show remorse for something he didn't do. I know I didn't kill nobody. I know I was never in downtown Boston. I was never in a combat zone. So I thought that they make an terrible mistake. Again, psychological theories this time about culpability, would shape Fred's case. In the decades that followed, these theories would be revised. In 2012, a landmark Supreme Court ruling would say that lower courts made an error in treating adolescents like adults.
乔治城的克里斯·亨宁说，将弗雷德作为成年人审判（这开启了终身监禁的可能性）的决定根源，无法与种族偏见和历史问题剥离。“童年的概念从我们国家建立之初就从未赋予过黑人儿童。黑人儿童被视为财产，女性被用来繁衍黑人儿童以作为白人种植园的劳动力。因此，关于黑人儿童的深刻历史思考从一开始就在一个非常自觉的层面上开始了。而我们从未真正摆脱过这一点。”
Chris Henning at Georgetown said the roots of the decision to try Fred as an adult, which opened up the possibility of a life sentence, cannot be disentangled from the question of racial bias and history. The notion of childhood was never afforded to black children from the start of our country. Black children were perceived as property, and women were used to reproduce black children to serve as manpower for white plantations. And so the deep historical thinking about black children starts from the outset at a very conscious level. And we've never really moved from that.
乔治城大学的克里斯·亨宁表示，将弗雷德作为成年人进行审判的决定，开启了判处终身监禁的可能性，而这一决定的根源与种族偏见和历史问题密不可分。从我国建国之初，黑人儿童就从未被赋予童年的概念。黑人儿童被视为财产，而女性则被用来繁衍黑人后代，以充当白人种植园的劳动力。因此，关于黑人儿童的深层历史思考从一开始就处于一个非常有意识的层面。而我们从未真正摆脱过这一点。
This idea that black children couldn't be saved or redeemed, that they weren't children, has seeped into cultural norms and into the courts. It is no coincidence that the youngest person in a modern America to be executed was a 14 year old black boy. It is no coincidence that Emmett Till was 14 years old when he was lynched, and it's no coincidence that Tamir Rice was 12 years old when he was lynched, and it's no coincidence that Tamir Rice was 12 years old
这种认为黑人儿童无法被拯救或救赎，认为他们不是孩子的观念，已经渗透到文化规范和法庭之中。现代美国最年轻的被处决者是一名14岁的黑人男孩，这绝非巧合。埃米特·蒂尔（Emmett Till）被私刑处死时年仅14岁，塔米尔·赖斯（Tamir Rice）被私刑处死时年仅12岁，这绝非巧合，塔米尔·赖斯被杀时年仅12岁，这绝非巧合。
when he was gunned down by police. After the transfer hearing, Fred was sent to adult court. The severity of the potential consequences multiplied tenfold. In 1981, Fred and his co-defendant, 20-year-old James Watson, were tried together. There was no physical evidence tying Fred to Jeffrey Boyagean's murder, so the state relied heavily on its two eyewitnesses, Neil Sweat and Richard Dwyer. Both were called to the stand. Neil testified that as he watched from his window, he saw Fred bring his left hand across
当他被警察枪杀时。移送听证会后，弗雷德被送往成人法庭。潜在后果的严重性增加了十倍。1981年，弗雷德和他的共同被告，20岁的詹姆斯·沃森（James Watson）一起受审。没有任何物证将弗雷德与杰弗里·博亚吉安（Jeffrey Boyagean）的谋杀案联系起来，因此州政府严重依赖其两名目击者：尼尔·斯威特（Neil Sweat）和理查德·德怀尔（Richard Dwyer）。两人都被传唤出庭。尼尔作证说，当他从窗户向外看时，他看到弗雷德用左手横过
his body and then heard at least three shots ring out. Neil also made an in-court identification of Fred. I remember Neil Sweat getting on a stand saying that he saw me shoot this person. Fred also testified on his own behalf. The perpetrator who committed his crime was a left-handed person. I'm right-handed. The perpetrator that the witness that they say saw committed his this crime, I did a person as 5-8. I'm not 5-8. I was 5-4 back then.
他的身体，然后听到至少三声枪响。尼尔还在法庭上指认了弗雷德。我记得尼尔·斯威特站在证人席上说他看到我射杀了这个人。弗雷德也为自己进行了辩护。犯下这起罪行的肇事者是一个左撇子。我是右撇子。证人所说的那个犯下这起罪行的人，身高5英尺8英寸。我不是5英尺8英寸。我当时只有5英尺4英寸。
I might be 5-5 right now, so I was shorter. Fred's foster mother also testified. She backed up Fred's alibi. She explained that he was asleep at her home, that the house was under lock and key when the shooting took place. But the jury and prosecution preferred another theory. After the house was locked, Fred must have woken up and escaped through a window. So the only explanation was that he must have escaped out of the window, somehow gotten
我现在可能也就5英尺5英寸，所以我当时更矮。弗雷德的养母也出庭作证。她支持弗雷德的不在场证明。她解释说，枪击发生时，他正在她家里睡觉，房子是锁着的。但陪审团和检方更倾向于另一种理论。房子锁好后，弗雷德一定醒了过来，并从窗户逃了出去。所以唯一的解释就是他一定是从窗户逃了出去，不知怎么地
himself physically to the combat zone, gotten into the cab, driven in the cab to the murder scene, committed the murder, and then gotten himself back and climbed back in through, I guess, the same window so that he was back in the apartment the next morning. That was their theory of how he could have participated in this crime. Fred was aware throughout the trial. The things were not looking good for him. I had a feeling my mind in my heart that I was going to go to prison. I just didn't know for how much time I was going to do, but I knew I was going to go to prison.
亲自到了战斗区，上了出租车，开车到谋杀现场，犯下谋杀罪，然后又回到了那里，爬回了——我想是同一个窗户——这样他第二天早上就回到了公寓。这就是他们关于他如何参与这起犯罪的理论。弗雷德在整个审判过程中都很清醒。情况对他很不利。我心里有一种预感，我要去坐牢了。我只是不知道我要坐多久，但我知道我要去坐牢了。
The jury heard the case. They excused jury to go deliberate. Maybe two or three days later, they came back with a verdict and they found me guilty. The first reading murder, which means I got an unnatural life sentence at the age of 17 years old. They put a kid in prison. At a 17-year-old, for a murder, he did not commit. People say they want to know the truth, but when you're telling the truth, they don't respect the truth. They not listen to the truth.
陪审团听取了案件。他们让陪审团去商议。大约两三天后，他们带着裁决回来了，他们判我有罪。一级谋杀罪，这意味着我在17岁时被判处了非自然的终身监禁。他们把一个孩子关进了监狱。一个17岁的孩子，因为一起他没有犯下的谋杀案。人们说他们想知道真相，但当你告诉他们真相时，他们并不尊重真相。他们不听真相。
They don't accept the truth. And when I was growing up, they had this notions about kids should be seen and not heard. And I was being seen, but I was not being heard. At 17, Fred Clay was effectively sentenced to die in prison. For a little while, I thought about killing myself,
他们不接受真相。我成长过程中，人们有种观念，认为孩子应该被看见，但不应该被听见。我被看见了，但我没有被听见。17岁时，弗雷德·克莱（Fred Clay）实际上被判在监狱中度过余生。有一段时间，我想过自杀，
but I don't like admitting that, but I did. But that thought went in my mind quick, in the left, my mind quick. But that's how angry I was. Fred was given a grown man's sentence. Then he was sent to live in a grown man's prison. I was scared of my mind. So I was kind of not quite sure how I was going to survive prison, but at the same time protect myself and making sure that I don't get taken out of prison in a body bag.
但我不想承认这一点，但我确实想过。但那个念头很快就从我脑海中闪过，很快就离开了。但我当时就是那么愤怒。弗雷德被判处了成年人的刑罚。然后他被送进了一所成年人监狱。我当时吓坏了。所以我不太确定我该如何在那样的监狱里生存，同时保护自己，确保我不会被装在尸袋里抬出监狱。
A lot of guys that have been there for many years, they got certain tables that they sit in a childhood. People was getting murdered over seats in a childhood. I mean, they just do harm to you over a seat. So for three weeks when I first went to Walpole I didn't sit down nowhere. I ate my food standing up with my back against the wall, watching everybody while I'm trying to eat my food as quick as I can and get out of there. It was a dangerous place. And often I thought over the years that,
很多在那里待了很多年的人，他们有固定的桌子，那是他们的地盘。人们因为争夺地盘上的座位而被谋杀。我是说，他们仅仅为了一个座位就会伤害你。所以当我刚去沃尔波尔（Walpole）监狱的前三周，我哪儿也不敢坐。我站着吃东西，背靠着墙，一边盯着每个人，一边尽可能快地吃完饭，然后离开那里。那是一个危险的地方。多年来我经常想，
even though my life situation wasn't great back then, my family wasn't, my family life wasn't great, but they took me out of a bad situation and they put me in even a worse situation. Because they was telling me that they don't care about my life. I can get killed in prison. So in a way, they was put me in harm's way.
尽管我当时的生活状况并不好，我的家庭也不好，我的家庭生活并不好，但他们把我从一个糟糕的环境中带走，把我放进了一个更糟糕的环境中。因为他们是在告诉我，他们不在乎我的生命。我可能会在监狱里被杀。所以从某种程度上说，他们把我置于危险之中。
As Fred served his sentence, the misconception that he was twisted and incapable of change followed him. Many educational programs were close to him. As a prisoner with a life sentence, the implication was that there was no reason to rehabilitate him. He was never going to get out. Eventually Fred did get into a few programs that would have him. Once I started doing that, my ideas about myself, about my time, about who I was as a person changed.
当弗雷德服刑时，关于他扭曲且无法改变的误解一直伴随着他。许多教育项目对他关闭。作为一名被判终身监禁的囚犯，这意味着没有理由对他进行改造。他永远不会出狱。最终，弗雷德确实参加了一些愿意接纳他的项目。一旦我开始这样做，我对自己的看法、对时间的看法、对自己作为一个人的看法都改变了。
He started to get to know other inmates who were also serving life sentences. They hung out sometimes and talked about what they would do if they ever got out. One time they were watching a TV show about extreme sports. They had skydiving, they had bungee jumping, they had a white water rafting, and then someone started talking about, you know, if I would get out of prison, I want a skydiving, I want a bungee jump, I want to go to a hot air balloon. And it just seemed like they was free. By this point, Fred had already spent 18 years in prison. He was in his mid-30s. He kept doing his time without any hope of ever getting out. Then, in 2012, in today's
他开始结识其他同样被判终身监禁的囚犯。他们有时会聚在一起，谈论如果有一天能出狱他们会做什么。有一次他们正在看一个关于极限运动的电视节目。里面有跳伞、蹦极、白水漂流，然后有人开始说，你知道，如果我能出狱，我想去跳伞，我想去蹦极，我想去坐热气球。这看起来就像他们自由了一样。到这个时候，弗雷德已经在监狱里待了18年。他已经30多岁了。他继续服刑，没有任何出狱的希望。然后，在2012年，在今天的
program, we're covering three new rulings issued by the Supreme Court. One of them, a decision against mandatory life sentences for juveniles in homicide cases. The Supreme Court ruled that mandatory sentences of life without parole for juveniles in homicide cases was unconstitutional. In a five to four ruling, the justices said such blanket sentences violate the Aether Amendment ban on cruel and unusual punishment. They said children who commit crimes, even serious ones, are different from adults. For the first time, Fred became eligible for parole. This was in April of 2015.
节目中，我们将报道最高法院发布的三项新裁决。其中之一是反对在凶杀案中对未成年人判处强制性终身监禁的裁决。最高法院裁定，在凶杀案中对未成年人判处不得假释的强制性终身监禁是违宪的。大法官们以五比四的投票结果表示，这种一刀切的判决违反了第八修正案关于禁止残酷和异常惩罚的规定。他们说，犯罪的儿童，即使是严重的犯罪，也与成年人不同。弗雷德第一次获得了假释资格。那是在2015年4月。
I had gotten some mail from the parole board that said that Fred Clay was going to be up for parole hearing in May. That's Jerry Boyajin, the brother of the cab driver whose murder led to Fred's conviction. When Jerry showed up at the parole hearing, he had his mind made up about Fred. Then something changed. They bring Fred in and he's sitting there and the in the parole board question in him. And as he talked about how, you know, as soon as he got settled in prison, he started working on getting his GED that he, you know, and he said every, you know, every counseling opportunity they presented him he took.
我收到假释委员会的一些邮件，说弗雷德·克莱将在5月参加假释听证会。那是杰瑞·博亚吉安（Jerry Boyajin），那个出租车司机的兄弟，他的谋杀案导致了弗雷德的定罪。当杰瑞出现在假释听证会上时，他已经对弗雷德下定了决心。然后事情发生了变化。他们把弗雷德带进来，他坐在那里，假释委员会在审问他。当他谈到，你知道，他一在监狱里安顿下来，就开始努力获得普通教育发展证书（GED），他说，你知道，他们提供的每一个咨询机会他都抓住了。
And during this whole time, I'm thinking, this is not the person I was thinking he was. I can't reconcile this person with the assumptions that I had made about him. A few years earlier, Fred had started working with Lisa Kavanaugh, who is director of the Innocence Program in Massachusetts. They filed a motion for a new trial and claimed that, among other problems through the case, Fred's trial lawyer had not investigated evidence that two other men at the Archdale Housing Project may have killed Jeffrey Boyajin. In the intervening years, one of those men had been convicted of armed robbery arrested on the same road where Jeffrey Boyagein was killed. He had been described as about 5'8", and is using his left hand to hold a gun.
在整个过程中，我在想，这不是我以为的那个人。我无法将这个人与我对他所做的假设联系起来。几年前，弗雷德开始与马萨诸塞州无罪项目（Innocence Program）的主任丽莎·卡瓦诺（Lisa Kavanaugh）合作。他们提交了一份重审动议，并声称，除了案件中的其他问题外，弗雷德的辩护律师没有调查证据，即阿奇代尔住房项目（Archdale Housing Project）的其他两名男子可能杀害了杰弗里·博亚吉安。在随后的几年里，其中一名男子因武装抢劫被定罪，并在杰弗里·博亚吉安被杀的同一条路上被捕。他被描述为身高约5英尺8英寸，并用左手持枪。
The Suffolk County District Attorney reinvestigated Fred's case. DNA analysis of Jeffrey Boyagein's clothing turned up only his own DNA. Finally, in 2017, authorities agreed that Fred was entitled to a new trial. But the DA decided not to pursue charges, saying the new evidence raised significant doubt as to the fairness of his trial and the justice of his conviction, and that the interests of justice would not be served by the prosecution of this case. Instead of being released on parole to spend the rest of his life
萨福克县地方检察官重新调查了弗雷德的案件。对杰弗里·博亚吉安衣服的DNA分析只发现了他自己的DNA。最终，在2017年，当局同意弗雷德有权进行重审。但地方检察官决定不再追究指控，称新证据对审判的公正性和定罪的正义性提出了重大质疑，且起诉此案不符合司法利益。弗雷德没有被假释出狱并带着谋杀罪名度过余生，
with a murder conviction on his record, Fred's original conviction was thrown out, and he was exonerated. He is my honor and privilege to discharge you from custody. Nearly 38 years after he was arrested, Fred was free. To quote, say I'm cool. It's been a long time coming.
而是撤销了弗雷德最初的定罪，并宣告他无罪。我很荣幸能将你从拘留中释放。在他被捕近38年后，弗雷德自由了。引用一句，说我很酷。这一天来得太久了。
It's the first time I walked without shaggle, so it's strange, it feels strange. There's a lot of life I need to make up on. Just over a year later, Fred received a million dollars in compensation for Massachusetts. It was the maximum allowed under state law. Fred is trying to cope with the many changes that took place in the world while he was in prison. I'm doing okay, just trying to still learn how to deal with life out here. But as much as some things have changed, others remain exactly the same.
这是我第一次不用戴脚镣走路，所以很奇怪，感觉很奇怪。我有很多生活需要弥补。仅仅一年多后，弗雷德从马萨诸塞州获得了100万美元的赔偿。这是州法律允许的最高金额。弗雷德正在努力适应他在监狱期间世界上发生的许多变化。我做得还可以，只是还在努力学习如何处理外面的生活。但尽管有些事情发生了变化，其他事情却依然如故。
Every time I leave out my house now, I go to work. I go to store. No matter where I'm going, every time I leave my house, I wonder if something's gonna happen to me. Fred is afraid that he could end up getting killed by police. Sometimes I think being a prison, so to save my life in certain ways. Now I'm back out here, and my life can be taken for me, just by my and my life can be taken from me just by my business.
现在每次我离开家，我去上班。我去商店。无论我去哪里，每次我离开家，我都会担心是否会发生什么事。弗雷德担心他最终可能会被警察杀害。有时我想，在监狱里，在某些方面救了我的命。现在我回到外面了，我的生命可能会被夺走，仅仅因为我……我的生命可能会被夺走，仅仅因为我……
Walking to the bank, going shopping, going to try and get some eyeglasses, don't get my eyeglasses repairs and doing nothing wrong. And next thing though, I'm being shot or I'm being killed or I'm being choked or I'm having a need to mind neck. Fred also realizes that the feeling of being behind bars doesn't go away just because you are out of prison. He's had to work at feeling free. It's going to be frightening. I might feel like I'm falling. But there's no turning back. I have to deal with whatever life throws me at my weight. One of the first things Fred wanted to do after his release was to find a way to honor
去银行，去购物，去试着配眼镜，去修理眼镜，什么坏事都没做。接下来我知道的就是，我被枪击了，或者我被杀了，或者我被勒住了，或者我的脖子上被压着膝盖。弗雷德也意识到，那种身陷囹圄的感觉并不会因为你出狱了就消失。他必须努力去感受自由。这会很可怕。我可能会觉得我在坠落。但没有回头路了。我必须处理生活抛给我的任何事情。弗雷德获释后想做的第一件事就是找到一种方式来纪念
some friends from prison. He decided to do it by going skydiving. Some of these people end up dying in prison, so it was a way for me to say, well, he didn't get a chance to skydive. I did, so I'm living this moment through them. So it was a way for me to acknowledge them and to dedicate that moment to them. The second time he went skydiving, it was for himself. Stepping out of the plane felt like a metaphor for his life.
一些监狱里的朋友。他决定通过去跳伞来做到这一点。这些人中的一些人最终死在了监狱里，所以这对我来说是一种方式，说，好吧，他没有机会跳伞。我跳了，所以我通过他们体验了这一刻。所以这是一种承认他们并将那一刻献给他们的方式。他第二次去跳伞时，是为了他自己。走出飞机感觉就像他生活的一个隐喻。
When I opened the door and I felt that when I hit my face and I looked down and saw how high we was, I was scared, I was scared, but at the same time, it was one of my dreams for me to do that. So, I needed to do it. Once they open that door and you count down to jump out, and once you jump out, there's no turning back. You can't say, well, I changed my mind, I want to go back. There's no turning back. My journey back into my life right now is going to be scary,
当我打开门，感觉到风打在我的脸上，我往下看，看到我们有多高时，我很害怕，我很害怕，但与此同时，这是我的梦想之一。所以我必须去做。一旦他们打开那扇门，你倒数跳下去，一旦你跳下去，就没有回头路了。你不能说，好吧，我改变主意了，我想回去。没有回头路了。我现在回到我生活中的旅程将会很可怕，
it's going to be overwhelming, but I got to deal with whatever comes my way. I got to deal with that. And when I went skydiving, I had that thought. I got to deal with whatever life throws at me right now because I didn't think I was going to get out of prison. I thought I was going to die in prison. So my worst day out here is better than my best thing in prison. There were two distinct avenues through which ideas from psychology affected the Fred Clay case. Some of the techniques used, like hypnosis and Rorschach tests, have been largely discredited. But there were also implicit, unconscious issues that continued to play a pervasive role in the criminal justice system. Police pressure during interrogations, deeply embedded ideas about the criminality of black boys, leaping to assumptions about guilt, which produces the idea that someone who does not show remorse, must be remorseless instead of merely innocent. Fred is not the only one who was victimized by these errors and biases.
将会让人不知所措，但我必须处理任何出现在我面前的事情。我必须处理它。当我跳伞时，我有过那个想法。我现在必须处理生活抛给我的任何事情，因为我没想过我能出狱。我以为我会死在监狱里。所以我在这里最糟糕的一天也比我在监狱里最好的一天要好。心理学思想影响弗雷德·克莱案的途径有两种。一些使用的技术，如催眠和罗夏墨迹测试，在很大程度上已被否定。但还有一些隐含的、无意识的问题，在刑事司法系统中继续发挥着普遍作用。审讯期间的警察压力，关于黑人男孩犯罪倾向的根深蒂固的观念，急于做出有罪的假设，这产生了一种观念，即一个不表现出悔意的人一定是冷酷无情的，而不是仅仅是无辜的。弗雷德并不是唯一一个被这些错误和偏见所伤害的人。
Today, we still don't know who killed Jeffrey Boyajin. Fred's co-defendant, James Watson, has been behind bars for about four decades. His sentence was based in part on the same eyewitness testimonies that put Fred in prison. Just as Fred has done, James Watson is seeking a new trial. Recently, he was temporarily released from prison. It was an account of the COVID-19 pandemic and because of the strength of his claim for a new trial. The judge wrote that he has a reasonable possibility of having his conviction overturned. This week's show was produced by Kat Shuknecht and Parthascha.
今天，我们仍然不知道是谁杀了杰弗里·博亚吉安。弗雷德的共同被告詹姆斯·沃森已经在监狱里待了大约四十年。他的判决部分基于将弗雷德送进监狱的同样的目击者证词。正如弗雷德所做的那样，詹姆斯·沃森正在寻求重审。最近，他被暂时从监狱释放。这是因为新冠疫情，也是因为他重审请求的力度。法官写道，他有合理的可能性推翻定罪。本周的节目由凯特·舒克内希特（Kat Shuknecht）和帕塔沙（Parthascha）制作。
It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu and Laura Quarral. We had engineering help from Josh Nuewell and Josephine Neonai. Our unsung heroes this week are Alex Whiting and Scott Stangle. Alex and Scott helped us record Fred Clay's interview at their studio in Lowell, Massachusetts. This was the first interview we've done at the studio since the coronavirus pandemic began. Scott and Alex helped make sure Fred not only sounded great, but was also safe and comfortable.
由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）和劳拉·夸拉尔（Laura Quarral）。我们得到了乔什·纽威尔（Josh Nuewell）和约瑟芬·尼奥奈（Josephine Neonai）的工程帮助。我们本周的无名英雄是亚历克斯·怀廷（Alex Whiting）和斯科特·斯坦格尔（Scott Stangle）。亚历克斯和斯科特帮助我们在马萨诸塞州洛厄尔（Lowell）的工作室录制了弗雷德·克莱的采访。这是自新冠疫情开始以来我们在工作室进行的第一次采访。斯科特和亚历克斯确保弗雷德不仅听起来很棒，而且安全舒适。
Thanks to both. A big thank you to our voiceover actors, Graham Smith, Ristibo, and Dylan Scott. For their help tracking down the source material for this episode, thank you to Clark Francis Conelli and Terence Locke of the Massachusetts Supreme Judicial Court. Chris Borrell at WGBH shared some of his own audio reporting about Fred Clay with us. We're very grateful. Thanks also to
感谢两位。非常感谢我们的配音演员格雷厄姆·史密斯（Graham Smith）、里斯蒂博（Ristibo）和迪伦·斯科特（Dylan Scott）。感谢马萨诸塞州最高司法法院的克拉克·弗朗西斯·科内利（Clark Francis Conelli）和特伦斯·洛克（Terence Locke）帮助我们追踪本集节目的原始素材。WGBH的克里斯·博雷尔（Chris Borrell）与我们分享了他自己关于弗雷德·克莱的一些音频报道。我们非常感激。还要感谢
the Test Neal at Arizona State University, Stephen Lynn at Binghamton University and Lawrence Petihis at the University of Potsmouth. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantantham and this is NPR. is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
亚利桑那州立大学的尼尔（Test Neal）、宾汉姆顿大学的斯蒂芬·林恩（Stephen Lynn）和朴茨茅斯大学的劳伦斯·佩蒂希斯（Lawrence Petihis）。想了解更多Hidden Brain的内容，请在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantantham），这是NPR。这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。